and my students hate this but you know
what I do I won't let them sit in their
favorite seats I move them around from
seat to seat I force them to work with
different people so that there are more
accidental bumps in the network where
people get a chance to connect with each
other and we studied exactly this kind
of an intervention at Harvard University
and at Harvard when you look at the
rooming groups there's freshmen rooming
groups people are not choosing those
roommates there of all different races
all different ethnicities many people
are initially uncomfortable with those
roommates but the amazing thing is at
the end of a year with those students
they're able to overcome that initial
discomfort they're able to find deep
level commonalities with people so the
takeaway here is not just take someone
out to coffee it's a little more subtle
it's go to the coffee room and when
researchers talk about social hubs what
makes a social hub so special is you
can't choose you can't predict who
you're going to meet in that place and
so with these social hubs the the
paradox is interestingly enough to get
randomness it requires actually some
planning in one university that I worked
at there was a mail room on every single
floor what that meant is that the only
people who would bump into each other
are those who are actually on that floor
and who are bumping into each other
anyway at another university I worked at
there was only
one mail room and so all the faculty
from all over that building would run
into each other in that social hub a
simple change in in planning a huge
difference in the traffic of people and
the accidental bumps in the network and
here's my question for you what is what
are you doing that breaks you from your
social habits where do you find yourself
in places where you get injections of
diversity unpredictable diversity right
and my students give me some wonderful
examples they tell me when they're doing
pickup basketball games or my favorite
example is when they go to a dog park
they tell me it's even better than
online dating when they're there so be
the the real thing that I wanted to
think about is we've got to fight our
filters we've got to make ourselves a
little more inefficient and by doing so
we're creating a more imprecise social
search engine and you're creating that
randomness that luck that is going to
cause you to widen your travels through
your social universe but in fact there's
more to it than that
sometimes we actually buy ourselves a
second-class ticket to travel our social
universe we are not courageous when we
reach out to people let me give you an
example of that a few years ago I had a
very eventful year that year I managed
to lose a job I managed to get a dream
job overseas and accepted I had a baby
the next month I got very sick I was
unable to take the dream job and so in a
few weeks what ended up happening was I
lost my identity
as a faculty member and I got a very
stressful new identity as a mother and
what I also got was tons of advice from
people and the advice I despised more
than any other advice was you've got to
go network with everybody when your
psychological world is breaking down the
hardest thing to do is to try and reach
out and build up your social world and
so we studied exactly this idea on a
much larger scale what we did was we
looked at high and low socioeconomic
status people and we looked at them in
two situations we looked at them first
in a baseline condition
when they were quite comfortable and
what we found was that our lower
socioeconomic status people when they
were comfortable they were actually
reaching out to more people they thought
of more people they were also less
constrained in how they were networking
they were thinking of more diverse
people then the higher status people
then we asked them to think about maybe
losing a job we threatened them and once
they thought about that the networks
they generated completely differs the
lower socioeconomic status people they
reached in words they thought of fewer
people they thought of less diverse
people the higher socioeconomic status
people they thought of more people they
thought of a broader network they were
positioning themselves to bounce back
from that setback let's consider what
this actually means imagine that you are
being spontaneously unfriended by
everyone in your network other than your
mom your dad and your dog okay this is
essentially what we are doing at these
moments when we need our networks the
most right imagine this is what we
remember doing it to ourselves we are
mentally compressing our networks when
we are being harassed when we are being
bullied when we are threatened about
losing a job when we feel down and weak
we are closing ourselves off isolating
ourselves creating a blind spot where we
actually don't see our resources we
don't see our allies we don't see our
opportunities how can we overcome this
two simple strategies one strategy is
simply to look at your list of Facebook
friends and LinkedIn friends just so you
remind yourself of people who are there
beyond those that automatically come to
mind and in our own research one of the
things we did was we considered Claude
Steele's research on self affirmation
simply thinking about your own values
networking from a place of strength what
Lee Thompson who in Sokcho and I were
able to do is we found that people who
had affirmed themselves first were able
to take advice from people who would
otherwise be threatening to them here's
a last exercise I want you to look in
your email inbox and I want you to look
at the last time you asked somebody for
a favor
I want you to look at the language that
you used did you say things like oh
you're a great resource or I owe you one
I'm obligated to you all of this
language represents a metaphor it's a
metaphor of economics of a balance sheet
of accounting of transactions and when
we think about human relations in a
transactional way it is fundamentally
uncomfortable to us as human beings we
must think about human relations and
reaching out to people in more humane
ways and here's an idea as to how to do
so look at words like please thank you
you're welcome
in other languages look at the literal
translation of these words each of these
words is a word that helps us impose
upon other people in our social networks
and so the word thank you if you look at
it in Spanish Italian French
gracias grazie merci in French each of
them are grace and mercy they're godly
words there's nothing economic or
transactional about those words the word
you're welcome is interesting the great
persuasion theorist Robert childen he
says we got to get our favours back so
we need to emphasize the transaction a
little bit more he says let's not say
you're welcome
instead say I know you'd do the same for
me but sometimes it may be helpful to
not think in transactional ways to
eliminate the transaction to make it a
little bit more invisible and in fact if
you look in Chinese the word vu coogee
in Chinese you're welcome means don't be
formal
we're family we don't need to go through
those formalities and come Bali an
Indonesian is come back to me when you
say you're welcome next time think about
how you can maybe sometimes eliminate
the transaction and instead strengthen
that social tie maybe it's great to
collaborate or that's what friends are
for okay I want you to think about how
you think about this ticket that you
have to travel your social universe
here's one metaphor it's a common
metaphor life is a journey right it's a
train ride and you're on this train
you're a passenger on the train and
there's certain people with you
certain people get on this train and
some stay with you some leave at
different stops new ones may and
I love this metaphor it's a beautiful
one but I want you to consider a
different metaphor this one is passive
being a passenger on that train and it's
quite linear you're off to some
particular destination why not instead
think of yourself as an atom bumping up
against other atoms maybe transferring
energy with them bonding with them a
little and maybe creating something new
on your travels through the social
universe thank you so much and I hope we
bump into each other again